in this lesson we're going to talk about
the rules of exponents and go through
some examples so first let's go through
some common formulas that you want to
know when it comes to working with
exponents so when you multiply and the
bases are the same remember you want to
keep that base and then add the
exponents if you're dividing and you
have the same base you want to subtract
the exponent so the numerator's exponent
minus the denominator's exponent if you
have a power to a power you multiply the
exponents
anything to the zero power is one
anything that has a negative exponent
you take the reciprocal or move it to
the other side of the fraction okay and
make it a positive exponent and then if
you have a fraction raised to a power
you can distribute that power to the
numerator and the denominator so those
are some rules you want to refer to and
just review
uh when going through
your study of exponents but let's go
through some examples and see if you can
do these on your own and we'll go
through them together
so this first one 25x cubed minus 5x to
the ninth all divided by 5x squared what
does that equal
well what you want to do is you want to
divide
both of these quantities
by 5x squared so 25 divided by 5 is 5. x
cubed divided by x squared we subtract
because we're dividing 3 minus two is
one so that's five x
over here we've got a negative five
divided by five which is negative one
okay and then x to the ninth divided by
x squared nine minus two is seven so we
get x to the seventh now one times
anything is itself so we could just
write this as 5x
minus x to the 7th
okay example number 2 it says 5 to the
2x minus 3 equals 1.
well remember anything to the 0 power
equals 1. so that means in order for
this to equal
two x minus three has to equal
zero
so if we solve that equation by adding
three to both sides
you get two x equals three and divide
both sides by two
x equals three halves okay and then the
third example it says what does m minus
n equal
okay well let's take a look here well it
looks like we're squaring both this left
side here so why don't we just uh
take the square root of both sides okay
so the square and the square root cancel
so we get x to the m over x to the n
equals the square root of x to the tenth
is x to the fifth okay
and then when you
divide you subtract so this is x to the
m minus n equals x to the fifth so you
can see that because we have the same
base here m minus n must equal five so
that's it your answer would be five for
the third example so review the rules of
exponents and be familiar with those so
that you'll be able to do these types of
problems on the act